we're told that hannah and martine each
got a plant for their home
hannah measured that her plant grows on
average
two centimeters per week
martine
measured that her plant grows on average
three millimeters per day
which plant
grows faster
pause this video and see if you can
figure that out on your own
all right now let's go through this
together so first when you look at it
you might just compare three to two and
say oh three is larger than two
therefore maybe martinez plant grows
faster and you would think that until
you look at the units this is
millimeters per day while for hannah's
plant it's in centimeters per week so in
order to really compare them we have to
convert them to the same units in both
length and time so let's convert both of
them let's convert them both to
centimeters per week you could just try
to convert both of them to millimeters
per day or i guess you could try to
convert both of them to meters per year
with a third set of units but
centimeters per week seems reasonable
since we already have hannah's plant
rate at so let me write this down so
hannah i'll just you write h grows at
two centimeters
per
week and then you have martine
martine
grows at an average of
three
millimeters
per
day
now how do we convert three millimeters
per day to centimeters per week
well first we could convert the
millimeters actually first let's convert
the days into weeks so how many days are
there in a week well there's seven days
in a week so if we if we have how many
millimeters per day if we wanted to know
millimeters per week we would multiply
times seven days so let me do that so
times seven
days
days in a
week
that would get us this would be equal to
3 times 7 which is equal to 21
millimeters
millimeters
in a week
and you can see actually that the units
cancel out nicely like that so you're
left with millimeters a week and that
makes sense three millimeters a day
you're able to do seven times that in a
week 21 millimeters a week and then when
you think about 21 millimeters is how
many centimeters
well we just have to remember that one
centimeter is equal to 10 millimeters so
if we want to convert this into
centimeters we essentially have to
divide by 10 we could just say one tenth
of a centimeter per
millimeter and then that gets us we
could write in different ways but we
could write this and even here the units
cancel out nicely
21 divided by 10 is 2.1 centimeters per
week
centimeters
per
week another way you could have just
thought about it is we could say one
centimeter is equal to 10
millimeters
or if you divide both sides by 10
one-tenth of a centimeter is equal to
one millimeter
and if one millimeter is equal to
one-tenth of a centimeter then
21 millimeters it's just going to be 21
times this 21 times 1 10 is the same
thing as 21 divided by 10 it would be
2.1
centimeters
and so now we can compare 2.1
centimeters per week compared to 2
centimeters a week well it turns out
that when you actually compare
the appropriate units
it still turns out that martinez plant
is growing just a little bit faster